Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter, Author,
Director, Producer:And when the movie came
out it was instantly great, I mean it was
instant instantly profitable, and one of the
coolest things about it was I didn't even
release it for people to rent or purchase.
Film Courage: How much money was going into your
movies when you were dealing with the financiers?
Joston: We always made sure we didn't spend
more than a hundred, we never spent more than a
hundred. Unless you're shooting with massive names
or if you're shooting something that of course
if it's something that is going to use up most
of the budget like I just finished working with
someone who's doing a film where it's dinosaurs
and it's a very different thing so a lot of money
is going to go towards CGI and all that stuff
but if you're shooting the kind of movies that I
shoot that rely on practical effects and things
of that nature and the stars are not huge and
stuff like that, I don't believe it should go over
a hundred. I believe anytime you're going over 100
you're really rolling the dice. I
think you're rolling the dice anyway
but you're really rolling the
dice over a hundred because
I believe that with a smart marketing plan even
with a bunch of flaws you can make back a hundred.
If you go to 250 you go to 350 and you don't have
huge names attached or if you don't have a whole
lot of marketable elements, you could dig a hole
that you can't climb out of. So it's always been
under 100 and I try to keep most of my movies
under 100 and if you factor in a lot of the
the discounts I receive on things you could really
see my budgets kind of coming in at around 250.
that that's what they would be like if I was
being charged full rate for a lot of things
and so 100 sorry for the entire production
including posts and deliverables and and
prints and advertising yes okay and were all those
films profitable that had financiers attached
I would say that in the beginning no they didn't
they became they became more profitable after I
got them back and after I marketed them myself the
reason being is this and that's why I just gave up
one answer a one-word answer of no
and the reason is because earlier on
I thought if I give my film to a distributor
then that distributor is going to market my phone
they're going to sell it all over the place and
then I'm just gonna break in a bunch of money and
it'll be awesome and that's not really what
happens a distributor basically places your film
and if no traffic gets driven to those places you
don't make any money so ultimately it's your job
your responsibility as a filmmaker to drive
traffic to that film or to to drive traffic
to those places where it can be purchased right
or rented or whatnot so if you're not doing that
you're not making money and if you this I mean
back in the day when sales agents really mattered
that sales agent could take the film and sell
it here and sell it there and sell it there but
nowadays that doesn't really matter
unless it's a huge film or it has
a very huge name attached even though those things
don't matter so you have to understand not only
that it's your responsibility to do so but you
have to also understand how to accomplish it
how to drive traffic to those places so that you
make money so no when those films were released
they were not profitable then
but they are profitable now
so it's not just enough to get a distributor
to put it on iTunes or google play or whatever
you've got to have a plan in place to get eyeballs
to go to those links correct correct that was that
was one of the biggest lessons I had to learn
and not only learning that that was my job
but figuring out how to do it because it can be
very tricky it can be very tricky because the the
amount of films that are out that are constantly
coming out is just crazy and if you think about it
as as filmmakers most filmmakers think oh this
person's in the film this part and all these
people know other people and everybody's talking
about my film amongst each other oh man I'm doing
it it's huge and it's like no because you're
just talking to other people in the industry
and yeah everybody else in the
industry is talking about it but
they're really not your audience and they're
really not the people who are going to
make your film a success they're not unfortunately
the audiences the people who you're marketing the
film to in terms of a paying audience who that's
their interest that's that those are the people
who you want to be aware of your film those are
the people who you want talking about your film
and as I began to notice it more
and more I even took my own personal
facebook page down I took it down because it
was for what I was doing it was worthless and
it was a waste of time because everybody who I
knew worked in the industry and we all pumped
each other up and oh you're awesome and that stuff
doesn't matter that stuff does not pay the bills
pumping each other's ego up is that's all it's
doing is pumping you pumping each other's ego up
so I got away from that completely and started
really focusing on how do I find my audience
and how do I keep them engaged and then
how do I best convert that audience
to a paying audience how do I best do that and
those were things I just learned along the way
so maybe your audience let's say would be the
people that would attend a horror convention in
middle America rather than people on either coast
that are also looking to be cast correct okay but
unfortunately and you don't know it really on
on on like when you're on like a me social media
platform like facebook everybody's friending
you friending you like oh my movie's so popular
and it's only after you sit back and you look
at it that you realize man every single one of
these people are either actors or composers like
what is this like I got 7 000 friends well I have
5,000 friends and 4 thousand and 800
of them are other actors and composers
like that's the list of and that's not my
audience that's not who I'm really looking to
to convert those are the people
who I'm looking to keep engaged
they're already engaged because they're looking
for work so I had to learn how do I how do I find
my audience and how do I keep them engaged how do
I keep them happy and I really started to notice
when I got ax man back and I just kind of put out
a blurb about it guess what guys I got it back
and then everybody was like oh that's awesome
blah blah blah and what are you going to do now
oh I'm going to re-edit it oh you're going
to re-edit it how's it gonna be different
and people were actually really engaged and and
we had a lot of back and forth and I had people
writing me I always thought this should
have happened in the movie and I'm like
we already shot it it's like it's I'm re-editing
but I'm not going back reshooting things it's been
a while I think everybody's aged at this point but
just looking to go back and re-edit it and then
get it closer to the vision that I had for it and
they were just so excited and engaged and when the
movie came out it was instantly great I mean it
was instant instantly profitable and one of the
coolest things about it was I didn't even release
it for people to rent or purchase I released it
directly to Amazon Prime and Tubi TV and that
was it just those two just those two platforms
now it's since expanded but just I would even say
even if you remove Amazon from the equation which
if most filmmakers haven't they should in terms
of AVOD or in terms of SVOD you should remove
that from the from your overall vision of how much
money the movie's gonna make and really focus on
places like Tubi because that's where I would say
95 of the revenues come from has been from Tubi
and with Tubi are there forced ads yeah yeah so
you you have to watch the ads sure you have to
watch and and I think every movie it starts
with like two or three ads and then it goes
into the movie and then a few minutes in it's
another four or five ads and then they go and so
if you keep people engaged if you have quality
content you keep people engaged each time they
pass one of those commercials you're making more
money and so that's the name of the game is is
AVOD for for certain movies for certain movies
now if you have a movie like the my most recent
film one-to-one if you have something like that
where you have a couple of names that are in the
movie that people recognize that's something you
want to really push and see what TVOD has to offer
transactional video because the odds are a lot of
people will go there to rent or purchase that film
because they recognize those people and because
the content may be something they're interested in
did you use an aggregator to get it on to be or
Amazon Prime or these other you said with the v
sorry with the watson want you yeah with the
smaller films I go through FilmHub actually
FilmHub is a great resource because mainly because
I think for most people the barrier to entry is
too high from going with a traditional aggregator
because they're going to charge you per platform
they're going to first of all have a set fee and
then any platform after that is another fee and
another fee and another fee and another fee right
now if you anticipate and when I say anticipate I
don't mean hope but you you've actually done the
homework and you anticipate making I don't know
500 grand right unless I'm just going to use that
ballpark figure if you anticipate making 500 grand
from your film and you went through
an aggregator then you paid them up
front so that's all they got so if you paid
them if you paid them up front and it was
2 500 bucks then that's all they got and you got
all the rest of that money but if you went through
FilmHub well FilmHub you didn't pay anything
up front they take I think it's I think it's 10
so if they're taking 10 then they took 50 000
which is huge but if you anticipate because
you've done the research and films in your certain
budget range they maybe only hit a certain number
then and that you're gambling anyway then FilmHub
is better because there's no real barrier to entry
you can just put the film in see how it does
and let's say you crap out at ten thousand right
game's over it's made up it's made ten thousand
and from now it's petering out then you didn't
spend anything to get into the game and if you if
FilmHub takes their percentage they've only taken
a thousand dollars is there a period of time when
the film kind of peaks or it depends on the title
in terms of like viewership is it the first month
I think it all depends I think it depends on
your how you've promoted the film or if you
even know anything about promoting because
I didn't in the beginning and I know my
film came out I know people were watching it
but I had no idea how they were watching
it I never sent them anywhere to watch it
grew a following but I don't know how much
of that was how much of that was from them
finding the actual places where it was being
shown and watching it through there or just
watching a pirated link I would have no way of
knowing because I never I never invested the
time in understanding how to market to an audience
so I didn't have that information at my disposal
but as I as I moved more into understanding the
marketing of a film I can say that I usually will
feed that audience engage that audience and then
point them to where I need them to go and I can
watch the film through every quarter actually with
FilmHub because you can piece out the rights you
can take the rights and do this by yourself and
then FilmHub only handles this but of everything
I'm seeing I can see it month by month what's
happening and see how much money I'm generating
how many views I'm getting month over month
and I usually find that in the first quarter
that's where you get the larger number of
people viewing your film because that's when
it's still hot that's when it's most exciting and
everybody wants to watch it and see what happens
and then it starts to kind of find a little medium
and it rise that probably for another two quarters
and when you say peace out the rights what does
that mean meaning you own it in perpetuity but
then they own it for a certain time certain
amount of uses no actually FilmHub doesn't
they you're not even you're licensing it to them
but it's for no predetermined amount of time so
at any moment you can just stop it you can say
what I'm not liking this anymore I'm just going
to stop it now and you can choose to do so and
what I mean by piecing out is if you're going
to I mean it's different now but in the beginning
if you wanted to keep Amazon rights for yourself
because ultimately why would you want somebody to
upload to Amazon when you could do that yourself
so for a lot of people they kept the Amazon rights
themselves and then they would put the rest of
their the rest of the platforms on on FilmHub
and then they would make all their money that way
and so as Amazon has moved away from
allowing direct uploads for a Prime
they've moved away from that recently so I say
recently like it was just now but I think it
was beginning of 2021 they they moved away from
that model so yes you can upload your film and
it can be TVOD for rent for purchase but
it won't go to Amazon Prime unless it was
put up by another distributor or an aggregator
really do why they did that I mean the rumor is
that it was because so much of Prime was cluttered
with not that quality content because people were
saying oh it's a feature film and really it was
just a bunch of episodes of uh something they
put on youtube like like like them what was
one of the ones that was like a tutorial on
something like nails and stuff or something
they just put together a bunch of episodes and
it equaled out to like 45 minutes and they just
uploaded that and now that's considered a movie
and so I think Amazon just they got enough
backlash from that and they decided it's
it's not worth it for us to allow people to do
that now we need somebody curating that content
I think that was part of it I think the other
part of it too is ultimately Amazon creates
their own content and so you're even though
I know I know a lot of people think that
we're not really in competition with with Amazon
because they have these huge big shows that are
watched by hundreds of thousands of people if not
millions of people we're not competing with that
and essentially yes you are you just not you
by yourself but if you and you and him and her
and we all got together and there was a thousand
films that hit Amazon Prime if you add up
all the people watching that content it is
rivaling their shows is taking attention away from
the stuff that they've created so I think it's
those two reasons in tandem that really pushed him
to make that decision and say I think let's put
an end to this let's make it a curated thing where
at worst I'm sorry at best they're going to have
to go through through FilmHub and and I think
so many people still don't know about FilmHub
and I think if you if you knew about FilmHub
as a as an independent filmmaker you would never
rely on another predatory distributor again
you never would because you realize they're
completely inconsequential you can give your
film away to this guy over here who will make
money off your film and you'll never see a dime
or you can do it yourself and put it on FilmHub
and chances of you saying money is far greater
it would keep people out of making some really
bad bad deals with distributors with bad intent
and do they have certain specs that they require
aspect ratios yeah yeah yeah yeah they they do
they do specify the the formats that
you must submit and they do specify
how many moments of black that you can have so
that the films are pretty uniform so you're not
having more than I think more than two seconds
of black at the beginning and not more than two
seconds of black at the end that sort of thing
just so that movies start because I know there
are people who try to pad things out and oh if I
throw on two minutes of black at the beginning and
five minutes of black at the end my movies now
83 minutes so I think they try to do that but but
ultimately it's just something to keep it uniform
why have you put your films on Tubi at the
moment it's probably the greatest revenue
generator because people get to watch it for
free it's a free app that's in pretty much
I would say almost every english-speaking
territory and even some non-english speaking
territories so it's widely available
just as much so as Amazon Prime and
it's it runs off ad revenue so it's completely
free unlike Amazon Prime where you have to have
a membership whatever you pay per year your
annual membership with Tubi you just download
the app to your phone or to the computer or
to your television and you're able to watch
films completely for free just everything all the
revenue is generated from from advertisements so
we recently heard that a filmmaker said that
he made like six figures from Tubi can you tell
us your experience six figures yeah definitely
possible I think it depends upon a lot of factors
I don't know if this filmmaker did it on one
film because that's a different set of factors
versus he just had a bunch of his films on
there and that's a different set of factors
but depending upon the factors yeah certainly
all that really all that really needs to happen
is that you drive an audience that
you've been interacting with to to be
the only the only pushback I would say I received
in terms of of why someone hasn't viewed a film
of mine on Tubi was just that they didn't know
what Tubi was they didn't know how much it was
going to cost so they didn't bother to download
it that's the only thing I think that as more
people become acquainted with Tubi I think that's
going to be the place to go to to place a film
and i've actually been in talks with them so
that I don't have to go through an aggregator
in order to place films there because all they
really want to see is that they're not dealing
with a filmmaker who has one film they want
to deal with someone who has multiple films
so that they aren't just dealing with one offs of
having to have different bank accounts to pay or
whatever so that's why they deal with aggregators
that's why they deal with distributors because
they're just paying one person for a lot of
films versus one-offs so you don't have let's
say a dashboard within Tubi that you can go and
see what you made for this quarter I don't have
it because I don't have a direct relationship
with them yet but I'm about to have a direct
relationship with them for right now I see all
of my revenue projections from FilmHub okay right
why do you place such an emphasis
on owning your own movies
I believe that that is the only way to operate
with any type of freedom in this industry
to be tethered to a committee to be tethered
to someone who holds the purse strings it just
already this this industry you have to have
a thick skin already and it's an artistic
industry it's not like it's being an accountant or
something it's it's actually you relying on your
own creativity and your ability to take what's
ever in your head and apply it in reality to
make it come true right you're trying to do all
these things and and ultimately you have so many
people around you that are that could be whether
it's negatively or positively influenced in that
and manipulating it and they don't mean to they
don't mean to it's not like I don't think many
people are out to just screw you over with bad
ideas I think that everybody just wants their
own thing they want their own imprint on whatever
it is and it really hampers your your freedom and
your ability to grow but if you were able to
finance your own projects and you were able to
understand the distribution process so that you
understand how much money you generate from that
then you've taken so much of your own financial
freedom and your creative freedom into your own
hands that's why I really emphasize owning
your own rights and not I don't even license
my stuff out unless I know that this person can
do something that I can't do and even then I'm
only licensing the rights to them for the things
that I can't do on my own that's it because I know
that if I license as a license and to them for
I don't know two three years that's two or three
years that I'm tied to them on this specific thing
and if I learn how to do that in that specific in
that during that time I can't even do anything
about it because they're already doing it so I
have to wait until their license is up before I
can do it myself because I like to I like holding
me accountable I like making myself responsible
because that's the only way I know for sure 100
that it will get done and get done to the level
that I would do it or that I want it to be done
so in all of this what I'm trying to do is
take all of my projects and use them to not
only express myself artistically but also to
provide my own security moving forward you know.